le projet de loi de code de nationalité
n'est pas abandonné le garde des sceaux
albin chalandon donné cette précision
aujourd'hui dans le figaro
pour le ministre la réforme est
nécessaire mais pour revenir selon lui
il ya un climat de sérénité
une commission des sages a été créé
l'ancien ministre socialiste roland
dumas
apple lui à manille à maintenir la
pression contre ce projet et la
manifestation prévue demain est plus que
jamais maintenu comme le disait hier à
télématin harlem désir dans ce débat sur
le code de nationalité on a souvent fait
référence à ce qui se passe aux etats
unis
jean-claude parise correspondant
l'antenne de la new york apporte les
éléments américains de la controverse
julien à quatre ans son père est
français ne pour les américains il est
américain uniquement parce qu'il est né
en territoire américain
il a déjà droit à un passeport américain
et cette loi est aussi vieille que les
états unis la loi pour origine le droit
anglais et l'amérique l'avait adopté du
temps de la colonisation anglaise
mais aujourd'hui cette règle facilite
grandement les choses dans la mesure où
l'on connaît immédiatement la
citoyenneté d'une personne si elle est
née aux etats unis la personne est
américaine vous n'avez pas à vous
inquiéter de connaître la nationalité
des parents et de rentrer dans tous les
problèmes et confusion du système
européen la nationalité américaine peut
se perdre mais seulement dans de rares
cas par exemple quand on travaille pour
un gouvernement étranger ou bien quand
on choisi la nationalité d'un autre pays
même s'ils commettent un crime un
étranger naturalisé américain ne perd
pas forcément sa nationalité
vous pouvez perdre votre citoyenneté
américaine
votre nationalité si vous commettez un
acte criminel
dans la période précédant la date de
votre naturalisation mais tout acte
commis après coup ne vous ferai pas
perdre automatiquement cette même
citoyenneté américaine
la nationalité automatique pour
quiconque est né aux états unis a posé
problème car les parents peuvent se
prévaloir de la nationalité de leurs
enfants pour devenir eux-mêmes américain
beaucoup d'eau mexicaine d'autres
d'ailleurs ont traversé la frontière
pour accoucher mais la loi était
modifiée lui une dizaine d'années
maintenant pour se prévaloir de la
nationalité américaine de son enfant il
faut attendre que celui ci a 21 ans